this is how it happened this is how the
Batman died
nine months ago Joker was cremated I
pressed the button and burnt the evil
bastard myself and then we waited goth
embraced itself for the inevitable power
struggle but it didn't come crime
actually fell
deep down I knew war was coming I was
just waiting for someone
Thanks no problem oh thanks honey so
what'll it be your usual sure okay
chicken salad with no dressing no you
know what make it waffles with a side of
bacon don't tell my wife whatever you
say officer oh and if you want some more
coffee just shout with bacon on the side
hey I'm sorry to interrupt your dinner
officer uh Owens there's a guy smoking
over there in the corner booth yeah wait
here I'll have a word
one guy got 75 excuse me sir there's no
smoking in here
hey
this demonstration used just five ounces
of my latest toxin tomorrow this will
seem like child's play Gotham this is
your only warning
xmod
scarecrows threat war
yesterday there were six point three
million people in Gotham City today not
so many the only people left on the
streets of the sort that enjoy the chaos
Gotham's finest scum criminals
and worse not enough good people left to
stop
it took just 24 hours for us to lose
control of the city tonight Gotham's
relying on one man to save us all
you
you
don't forget we gotta go see pay later
he's got something special planned
you're going to glad you made it out
okay sorry I've got to go stay safe
Barbara you still know how to make an
entrance how's the evacuation going last
bus crossed the city limits an hour ago
I'm just glad my little girl got out
when she did now the real work begins
any lead on scarecrow we were tracking
an unknown military vehicle speeding
through Chinatown it's the only lead
we've had all night but they gave us the
slip with the evacuation I just don't
have the manpower left in the city if
you find it tell your men not to engage
I'll deal with it do you really think
scarecrows crazy enough to detonate a
chemical weapon in Gotham I won't let
that happen Jim in case you need to
reach me it's going to be a long night
Oh unit we got a 1033 in Sector two
missing patrol car unit 2 47 suspected
officer down hey Batman every damn time
Oracle I need the location of unit 247
already working on it how's my dad doing
he's holding up somehow he always does
okay i'm sending through this markers
location be careful not looking good out
there
if we will find something soon I'm
punching you in the face
I could use some help
you're safe thanks Batman I thought they
were gonna
the city's overrun we don't stand a
chance stay here I'll send someone to
pick you up what are you doing evening
the odds we're done for
oracle i need to track that military
vehicle a score cars picked up the
pursuit I'm relaying its location now
call off your Venture go foscar 56 this
is Commissioner Gordon I'm calling off
the bassoon it's too dangerous so here
we can take these bastards
they're getting away
just learning or fishing us
56 in order but Batman deal with this
Batman you've got to stop don't worry
kid he's fine
need to interrogate the driver and find
out what he knows
okay get away from me get away from
where scarecrow go to hell where is he I
got nothing to say to you Batman talk or
I'll crush every bone in your body okay
okay working out of a penthouse in
Chinatown swear that's all I know if
you're lying I'll bring the other one
Oracle check the chemical analysis I've
just uploaded sure is this what I think
it scarecrows new toxin an
uncontaminated sample you're not kidding
I'll prepare a full chemical breakdown
on the back computer what are you going
to do scarecrows got a safe house nearby
I'm going to pay him a visit let's hope
this is the brain we've been waiting for
this is the place I should check the
penthouse atop
he's going 3-3 their new anyway
do we keep her in there till we get the
order to kasares do your worst the
boredom is killing me oh don't worry
you'll get what's coming to you and
we're good and ready why do we have to
wait we can give her a dose now be my
guest I'll tell scarecrow was your idea
it was just joking didn't sound like a
joke I can't say I'm surprised you
should really review your security I
think Frieza faster reflexes
something tells me this was well that's
made things a little more interesting
sir Batman here were you expecting to
find me that man I'm afraid I must
disappoint you take a look at the
chamber I want you to know the fear that
is coming listen up that freak we're
walking out of here nice and slow you
try anything stupid a blow her brains
out charming but only one of us is
getting out of this cell
nothing like a little natural immunity
what are you doing here why did
scarecrow lock you up no hello tell me
and what if I don't want to then I burn
every plant and Gotham it started with
the meeting what meeting everyone was
there penguin to face Riddler even poor
Harley Scarecrow said he had a plan that
together we could take you out and
Gotham would be ours over my dead body I
believe that was the idea I told him
that I wasn't interested in his pathetic
human games and when I came to I was
locked up in that room it's such a shame
that his vile toxin has no effect on me
nature always wins
will he ever learn